[Musique]
jack lang bonjour bonjour vous avez été
le ministre de la culture dont l'action
a eu le plus d'impact sur notre société
de la fête de la musique jusqu'à
jusqu'aux journées du patrimoine vous
avez démocratiser la culture en ayant le
souci d'un carnet chacune de vos actions
sans jamais oublier d'en faire la
promotion alors on va voir avec vous
comment à travers votre parcours
la politique et la culture vous ont
amené jusqu'ici mais tout d'abord et
j'ai une question pourquoi jack plutôt
que jacques parce que mes parents et je
crois mon père surtout était anglophile
l'anglo feely a parcouru les siècles
notamment au xviiie siècle à l'époque
des lumières influence de l'ocs de
quelques autres philosophes et mon père
comme d'autres à ce moment là il était
un bourgeois moderniste laïc républicain
un vrai démocrate il est attiré par la
grande bretagne ses institutions sa
modernité voilà et leurs idées son idée
c'était de donner à leur premier enfant
un prénom britannique en 1939 lorsque
voilà être mais ils ont agité paraît-il
autres jack et william d'accord dès le
plus jeune âge
vous avez une passion c'est le théâtre
et c'est votre grand mère qui vous fait
découvrir le théâtre elle vous emmène à
nancy au théâtre elle vous emmène voir
ceci
[Musique]
le pays du sourire il l'opérette
oui c'est une très belle opérette le
pays du sourire de franz lehar ça va en
effet beaucoup touché il ya des airs des
paroles assez extraordinaire mon amour
et ton amour sont nés le même jour et
pour toujours et ça ça vous émeut à
l'époque quand vous voyez ça la première
fois quand vous avez six sept huit ans
je suis émerveillé d'abord par les ors
et les velours par le décor et sa magie
par l'histoire par les personnes et en
partie aussi parlé par ces paroles qui
sont restés dans ma mémoire et donc ça
va forger votre passion pour le théâtre
sevré parmi d'autres choses parce que le
moment je construisais un théâtre de
marionnettes
je compte réaliser avec une bande de
copains une petite petite troupe de
théâtre la fête c'était une passion le
théâtre et adieu pas sûr d'ailleurs vous
allez menthe et sur les planches vous
allez faire le conservatoire et pour
autant vous voulez pas être vous ne
voulez pas être comédien ni même metteur
en scène pourquoi c'est pour faire quoi
alors avec le théâtre qu'est ce qui vous
intéresse le bonheur d'être sur les
planches le bonheur de découvrir les teg
le bonheur de faire des tournées à
travers l'europe
donc j'étais conscient de mes limites je
l'aurais n'aurait pas été un bon acteur
pas davantage un bon vétéran scène voilà
c'est ouvre quand on prend conscience de
ses limites
on est capable de faire des choses
grands dossiers mais est-ce que vous
allez quand même vous servir du théâtre
pour faire autre chose
ah oui c'est à dire que j'ai créé un
ancien qui me manque de co quand j'avais
20 ans ce festival de théâtre
universitaire qui est devenu plus tard
le festival mondial du théâtre d'avant
garde qui a révélé un très grand nombre
de metteurs en scène aujourd'hui connue
mais à l'époque inconnue donc le théâtre
vous ne voulez pas en faire quelque
chose de créatif en tant que comédien
metteur en scène
en revanche vous avez une inspiration
pour influer sur la cité exactement
exactement donc j'aime le théâtre comme
spectateur comme organisateur comme je
dirais comme m
en chaîne d'événements et ça c'est ça ça
va vous définir ensuite en tout votre
parcours
alors pourquoi vous effectivement dans
les années 60 décidé à nancy puisque
vous êtes nancéen de créer le festival
mondial du théâtre universitaire vous
avez 24 ans pourquoi ce besoin de créer
un festival international dans une ville
moyenne comme nancy a précisé quand
c'est difficile c'est passionnant quand
c'est culotté c'est excitant et donc mon
idée c'était de pouvoir fait régner dans
cette ville très belle ville mais qui
n'est pas nécessairement connus dans le
monde entier des théâtres étudiants qui
s'est débrouillé pour financer leur
voyage qui partent avant dé leur bagnole
on fait des tombolas ou autre chose
et puis j'étais déjà passionné par
l'international par l'universel fait
revenir à soi le monde
cet excitant vous utilisez le théâtre
pour servir aussi votre ambition
personnelle d'une certaine façon
l'ambition personnelle vous ne
connaissez pas exactement puisque
j'étais entre plusieurs chemins
d'abord mes études de droit et je
voulais vous voulez absolument pour
différentes raisons
arrachez l'agrégation de droit le
théâtre oui on en parle à l'instant et
puis la conscience civique qui était né
chez moi comme chez d'autres à l'époque
au moment de la guerre d'algérie
lorsque cela s'est combiné sévi ce sont
entre coupé et enrichit mutual et d'une
certaine façon cette ambition de vouloir
devenir quelqu'un à nancy peut-être oui
c'est d'abord d'abord à nancy même quand
vous créez un tel événement ou suscité
la controverse et la paix et l'adhésion
oui effectivement assez vite je suis
devenu un personnage clé de la ville et
vous aimiez ça je ne déteste pas c'est à
dire qu'est ce que ça vous procurer
comme sentiment le la possibilité de
réaliser les choses il ya au moins le
goût de l'action
goode 2 mai thermique de la métamorphose
et donc du coup les portes s'ouvraient
pour obtenir le financement de ces
festivals qui avaient peu d'argent
et puis et puis la rencontre avec les
étudiants la rencontre avec les chefs
d'entreprise erp agir d'un côté briller
de l'autre briller je passais brillé en
tout cas agir et pour agir c'est vrai
que lorsqu'on vous connais un peu sa
facilité voies d'accès d'accord donc il
faut à un moment donné pouvoir être
remarqué c'est important quand vous
voulez agir
on peut dire ça et parfois il faut être
discret parfois le secret parfois il
faut pas se faire trop remarquer si on
veut agir
j'ai agi sur le plan politique par
exemple pour soutenir ceux qui se
battaient pour l'indépendance de
l'algérie
je n'ai pas fait de certains de manière
publique qui va car alors mais sur le
théâtre en tout cas ça a été un marqueur
et d'ailleurs au festival de nancy il ya
des futurs grands noms du théâtre qui
vont émerger comme par exemple pina
bausch bob wilson patrice chéreau ou
tadeusz kantor toile vidéo antoine vitez
c'est un théâtre d'avant-garde faire un
théâtre d'avant-garde c'est aussi une
façon de se démarquer de se singulariser
et donc d'être remarquée dans une ville
comme nancy qui est évidemment une ville
de province dont je ne cherchais pas à
provoquer mais simplement c'est vrai que
mon tempérament
la philosophie est porté à contester
l'ordre théâtrale dominant l'ordre
culturel dominant l'ordre social
dominant l'ordre universitaire dominant
et ont tous entre eux mais je répète le
théâtre était un théâtre généralement
engagées par de nouvelles formes
nouvelles esthétiques et aussi par des
idées qui à ce moment là c'est les
années 60 ans 63 les universités
communiqué lynn avec les jeunes à
travers des messages communs et comme
mai 68 est arrivé pour nous c'était
naturel c'est parce que vous aviez déjà
mené un théâtre politique exactement
alors dans ce festival là vous invité de
nombreuses personnalités et des
personnalités politiques comme françois
mitterrand dans les années 70 qui plus
tard plus tard qui devient
premier secrétaire du ps en quoi c'est
essentiel d'avoir des politiques à ses
côtés quand on est jack lang et qu'on
dirige ce festival la wii ce n'est pas
seulement françois mitterrand mais
françois lui rend bien sûr parce que
parallèlement nous organisions des
colloques des débats sur la la la
politique des arts sur la
décentralisation sur tout les sujets sur
les liens aussi entre l'époque
l'amérique latine étaient soumis à des
dictatures entre l'amérique latine et en
europe donc il y avait parallèlement des
confrontations politiques lots voulions
réunir des personnalités de différentes
obédiences
donc on voit que l'engagement politique
devient un axe majeur du festival
est-ce que dès cette époque là vous
trotte dans la tête l'envi de faire la
politique d'avoir une ambition politique
pas au sens propre mère belge était
engagé dans l'action peut déjà appartenu
à un moment ou un autre ont perçu puis
surtout j'ai été assez tôt bien avant de
connaître françois mitterrand très
attiré par pierre mendès-france que j'ai
fait venir annoncent ils pas au festival
une réunion que j'avais organisé pour
lui avec lui tu répètes il n'y a pas de
frontières pour me rappelle pas de
cloison entre mes convictions
philosophiques et mes convictions
artistiques
mais cette idée de d'avoir effectivement
ces deux mondes le théâtre les arts d'un
côté la politique vous emmène forcément
dans une direction qui est celle de
servir une ambition plus grande que
simplement un festival l'ambition si
vous voulez dire par là l'approché toute
possibilité de disposer de moyens plus
fort pour concevoir des projets
d'envergure voilà alors vous entré
pleinement politique en 1977 lorsque
vous intégrez le parti socialiste et
vous avez déjà une vision très claire
des réformes à faire en matière
culturelle
vous les avez rédigé quelques années
plus tôt dans différentes notes vous
souhaitez je cite ne plus enfermer la
culture dans des maisons dites de
culture mais de la faire jaillir dans
les milieux ouverts et innombrables vous
dit par ailleurs qu'il ne faut plus
confier les budgets des affaires
culturelles à la seule administre
a sion mais d attribuer aux créateurs
d'une certaine façon quand vous êtes
nommé ministre de la culture en 1981 est
une forme de logique à cela c'est vrai
que lorsque je suis choisi par françois
mitterrand pour prendre la tête de ce
ministère je ne débarque pas de vénus ou
de mars ou de l'administration ou de
l'ena ou d'ailleurs hier c'est le sait
la suite en effet d'inde d'un parcours
de plusieurs années d'engagement
culturelle et politique
d'ailleurs entre nous le festival nancy
et volantée gouvernement et toute
l'action que j'ai menée auprès de
françois mitterrand qui prenait toujours
le caractère à la fois culturelle et
politique
j'ai par exemple été le premier
directeur la campagne européenne au
suffrage universel et tous les
événements organisés dans tout le pays
était de ce même type est le seul vrai
ça a été au trocadéro va dans les
jardins du trocadéro rassemblement de
cent mille personnes en plein coeur de
paris
le london symphony orchestra dominant le
site et était présent évité dans les
plus grandes gloires du moment oui j
brand melina mercouri et les uns des
meilleurs
j'avais réussi avec l'appui de françois
mitterrand à conquérir paris un jour un
instant la mise en scène de l'action la
mise en scène d'un événement politique a
pris avec le théâtre notamment et c'est
ce que vous pensez ce qui fait que la
rencontre que vous avez eu avec françois
mitterrand vous permet ensuite d'avoir
la trajectoire d'incarner la culture
tels que l'huile imaginait je pense que
oui parce que on travaille ensemble
pendant deux ou trois ans il a pu
découvrir
mes défauts mais quelques qualités il a
dû percevoir ce que vous dites vous même
un homme d'action qui a une plongée
immergé dans la vie intellectuelle et
culturelle voilà avec un réseau
absolument considérable parce que c'est
ça aussi qui permet de pouvoir incarner
la culture et ça vous l'avez compris là
où les gouvernements de l'époque ne le
comprenait beaucoup beaucoup moins bien
peut-être oui et en retour nous étions
portés faut le dire par parle parle dans
la société par les articles par les
créateurs par les pro et les syndicats
culturel pas bon il y avait il y avait
une enthousiaste collectif très fort et
voilà et jour je suis arrivée rue de
valois
je sentais que j'avais une obligation de
réussir alors au moment où le président
est élu en 1981 ça fait donc des années
que vous mais les cultures et politiques
et vous allez avoir l'occasion de faire
une mise en scène de théâtre politique
la regarde et voici maintenant l'arrivée
de françois mitterrand sur la place du
panthéon certainement
[Musique]
lui demande de part et d'autre de la rue
soufflot la rue qui porte le nom de
l'architecte
commence à la construction de ce
panthéon sous le règne de louis 15
construction qui fut parachever terminé
par rondelet
ce panthéon que victor hugo qui devait
tester ressembler je suis heureux je
heureux de revivre par l'image
six balles approximatives il faut dire
son vieil n'ont pas été restaurée bon ce
qui a été un moment émouvant et
bouleversant de la vie politique
française
je me souviens que on peut se les
organisions sa l'organisions cela avec
des moyens de fortune mais tirons et et
continuer à agir comme des militants eh
bien on prend trois bouts de ficelle et
je me suis même trompé quand je lui ai
demandé s'il avait des points quand il
eut déposé 0 sur les trois tombes de
deux seuls sert de jean moulin et de
jaurès sortir seul le devant du panthéon
je vais totalement trompé d'année par
une môme était en retard j'ai tout fait
avant j'en sais rien et ce pauvre
président la république tout à coup
c'est trouver complètement asperges et
par un orage nous à l'ird et cinémascope
un orage hollywoodien mais finalement
c'était formidable parce que c'était
comme l' arme sa volée qui coule et se
sont bizarres qui rejoignait les larmes
que les gens nous titille qui coulait
des yeux de millions et de millions de
gens qui ce jour là ont ressenti une
émotion puissante alors il ya une mise
en scène de la vie collective que vous
avez ritualisé quand vous êtes devenu
ministre de la culture c'est la fête de
la musique aujourd'hui ça fait quasiment
40 ans
vous l'avez créé en 1982 en quoi c'était
essentiel de créer la fête de la musique
en quoi c'était important donc c'est de
suite logique de tout ce que j'avais
entrepris et cet argent aussi ma propre
conception de la vie de la société et de
la politique
je crois très profondément qu'on ne peut
faire bouger les choses qu'en proposant
aux gens aux citoyens d'être semaine co
inventeur ou qu'autant de leur vie la
fête de la musique c'est très simple
c'est de dire aux gens pètent fait
f ayité os fait doux reid fait faites le
vous même c'est vous qui allez créer
l'événement par des chorales par des
orchestres dans votre instrument de
musique
et c'est peut-être ça qui fait
d'ailleurs le succès de l'événement
c'est que aujourd'hui chacun se sent
quelque sorte propriétaire entre
guillemets d'un événement il ne
m'appartient pas qui appartient à la
mémoire à l'histoire et aux citoyens qui
en ont fait leur leurs moments de
rencontres chaque année et en même temps
je pense que ça vaudrait dans tous les
domaines et on est en même temps ça a
été créé à un moment donné où la france
traversait une grave crise une crise
économique majeure est ce que ça permet
aussi de deux d'adoucir les moeurs voire
de même resté populaire davantage
non ça permet surtout confiance de dans
ce pays qui est volontiers tourné vers
la déprime 3 qui et c'est important
qu'il y ait des moments de grâce des
moments d'exception des moments de
bonheur et vous remarquerez que cette
fête la musique
jamais depuis sa création on a connu une
seule violence sauf malheureusement l'an
dernier en raison d'une faute grave
commise par un commissaire de police à
nantes et jamais parce que chacun
respecte chacun et on se sent dans un
période à un moment si vous les ressorts
de soi même on rencontre les autres
alors quand vous êtes devenu ministre la
culture vous avez agi tous azimuts un
mise en place du prix unique du livre
journées du patrimoine grands travaux
votre budget le budget du ministère a
été doublé ce qui n'est jamais arrivé
par la suite sous la vème république
vous diriez que vous avez vécu une
période bénie une espèce de parenthèse
enchantée une certaine façon j'ai pas
parenthèse parce que dieu merci ce que
nous avons entrepris à ce moment là se
poursuit aujourd'hui
je veux dire par là et les inventeurs de
culture partout à travers le pays
les grandes institutions ont été
transformés la bibliothèque nationale le
louvre l'opéra et le reste donc ce
n'était pas une parenthèse c'est un
moment été conçu pour durer dans une
manière indépendamment des gouvernements
ce que nous avons lancée à l'époque
continue à porter ses fruits
simplement il ya des bêtas bon faut il
ya des changements c'est normal
non mais le les moyens qui ont été
emmenés à la culture en effet c'est une
période d'exception parce que la
conviction de françois mitterrand et de
notre équipe
c'était que la culture est au centre ont
laissé la première priorité
ce qui serait très difficile à dire
aujourd'hui je le pense toujours
et quand françois mitterrand ou moi même
nous exprimions à la radio télévision
pour dire c'est la priorité des
priorités avec la recherche scientifique
et l'éducation
tout le monde trouvait ça normal parce
que nous avions préparé les esprits
nous avions lancé des projets concrets
et tout à coup c'est devenu une espèce
de grandes ambitions
non pas individuelle mais collective
mais qui ne pouvait arriver qu'à ce
moment là avec ce président là avec ce
président là et à ce moment là en effet
c'est à dire que il ya une conjonction
de circonstances il ya eu une
préparation par les combats culturelles
menées antérieurement contre les gens du
pouvoir précédent
et puis je répète c'était cette
conviction a comme souvent nous oublions
le socialisme c'est d'abord un
changement culturel dans tous les sens
du mot et nous pensions vraiment la
preuve concrète si vous voulez en effet
le budget est doublée dès la première
année
mais françois mitterrand nous dit on va
l'augmenter chaque année un peu plus
jusqu'à atteindre le 1% et c'est ce qui
s'est passé là ont tenu les engagements
en 1983 crise alors vraiment une vraie
crise économique budgétaire plan de
rigueur de budget échappe aux coupes
le budget de la culture le budget de la
recherche idem d'ailleurs en 1992
lorsque un chômage de masse déferle sur
la france et sur l'europe et à ce moment
là j'ai arraché à nouveau et pour
l'éducation nationale dont le juge a dit
le ministre et pour la culture des
budgets d'exception il n'y a pas que les
budgets
bien sûr c'est très important il ya
surtout le désir de sans arrêt donné
naissance à des projets qui qui qui nous
permette d'aller au delà nous mêmes des
projets d'envergure des projets
détonnant où ou et kiki provisoirement
parfois provoque la polémique vous êtes
nostalgique de cette époque là non parce
que je continue à agir même esprit mais
j'ai un du contexte politique a le
concept politique en effet complètement
différent va pas répéter l'histoire est
donc ça ça vous manque
ça ne manque pas mais je persiste à
penser qu'il y aurait dans le futur à
concevoir de véritable révolution
culturelle éducative scientifique
sociétal mais ça demande des moyens
seulement avant les moyens ça demande
une détermination de faire et vous non
et oui diaz à couper au couteau
il en manque d'après vous nous sommes
dans une autre période dans un autre
système qui peut avoir ses vertus
j'ai pas envie de me mêler de la
politique d'aujourd'hui
alors vous avez été considéré comme le
ministre qui de la culture qui a eu le
plus d'impact sur la société
quel sentiment cela vous inspire
personnellement même au niveau de lego
quel sentiment cela vous inspire au
niveau de l'ailé gauche non mais on a
parlé au niveau de l'action je parle au
niveau personnel je ne peux pas être
insensible sur le plan subjectif dix ans
lorsque cinq jours des gens il
me parler de ce moment certains enfin
des mots parfois excessif un âge d'or où
un âge rêver bon je suis très touché et
en même temps pour répondre à votre
question
j'espère qu'un jour il y aura à nouveau
une renaissance de ce type vous en
doutez donc compte tenu du contexte
j'avais 10 ou par exemple moi je ne
voudrais pas du tout alors donc vous
avez été extrêmement populaire et en
même temps vous êtes un homme politique
a été souvent très critiqué et la rue la
critique qui revient souvent c'est que
jack l'homme jack lang pardon est un
homme qui cherche d'abord la lumière
c'est un metteur en scène de lui même
c'est quelqu'un qui a besoin d'être sous
le feu des projecteurs une forme de
narcissisme
comment vous avez vécu ces critiques ce
qui compte ce sont les choses sont les
axes ce sens c'est ce qu'on réalise
c'est comment concrètement au
transformer la société
mieux vaut suscité la controverse que
l'indifférence mieux vos fiches étaient
là les attaques un peu superficielle
voilà ça veut dire quoi des genres
existe mais surtout on agit d'accord et
l'avenir demain demain jack lang
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'être
président de l'institut du monde arabe
une institution unique au monde et qui
rejoint le lirai une vocation profonde
de notre pays notre pays et c'est à dire
depuis françois 1er
tourné vers l'orient a seulement aussi
vers l'orient vers vers le monde
méditerranéen vers l'orient vers le
monde arabe et devons être fiers
collectivement que cet institut soit non
pas roms n'ont pa londres n'ont pas à
washington mais a donc demain c'est
l'institut du monde arabe est votre
avenir vous le voyez là oui ma foi il
peut y avoir d'autres aventures je n'en
sais rien quel est votre rêve mais j'ai
pas le rêve c'est que chaque jour gg je
puisse rencontrer le bonheur d
autre d'accord vivre à travers l'action
puis vint la cure on vivra aussi la la
rencontre l'échangé les auteurs que je
découvre les films que je peux j'ai le
bonheur de rencontrer de voir et vous
arrive d'avoir des angoisses au sens
propre nom peut-être parce que je les
fuis vous définir peut-être parce que
j'ai fui l'ehpad angoisses
existentielles de leur temps qui passe a
le temps qui passe ou bien c'est à dire
mais je le refuse quand même comment pas
comment parce que j'y arrive pas je
n'arrive pas mais je crois que je ne
suis pas le seul à m'imaginer à croire à
mon état civil voilà c'est à dire je
crois que vous l'état civil a été
fabriqué il est complètement sûr fait
une invention d'un bureau voilà on
cherche à l'éternité d'une certaine
recherche l'éternité
et ça c'est lié avec ce que vous avez
fait sur la culture une forme de
recherche d'éternité on peut le dire
après coup dans la mesure où on peut
penser que ce que nous avons réalisé
avec françois mitterrand est appelée à
durer
on se souvient toujours plus d'un musée
qu'on a créé qu'une autoroute qu'on a
construite quand on est politique non
c'est vrai mais on fait pas ce calcul
pour cette raison que vous dites
j'avais alors pourquoi le choix n'est
pas d'ailleurs entre l'autoroute et la
pyramide du louvre non mais sans parler
d'un choix on peut se dire ça on sait
que ça va marquer que ça va être à la
une des journaux et surtout ça va rester
oui mais dans l'instant vous savez on
est surtout dans le combat pour faire
reculer les obstacles
même quand le quand on a la chance à un
homme comme françois mitterrand
président l'a annulée vous n'imaginez
pas à quel point de l'intérieur les
obstacles surgissent et résistance et
parle pas de la presse une partie de la
presse est opposée à la plupart de nos
réalisations
notre obsession c'était pas l'éternité
c'était de tenir bon jusqu'au bout pour
que ces projets qui étaient les nôtres
se réalise façon résistance face aux
résistances
résister c'est quand même un bon boulot
merci jack lang
[Musique]